that the truth of the law is essentially
reality no doubt again becomes for that
consciousness which remains at the level
of observation in antithesis to the
notion and to what is intrinsically
Universal in other words it does not
regard an object such as its laws having
the nature of reason but fancies that it
is something alien but it contradicts
its own belief in the fact that it does
not itself take its universality to mean
that every single sensuous thing must
have provided evidence of the law in
order to enable the truth of the law to
be asserted the assertion that stones
fall and raised above the ground and
dropped certainly does not require us to
make this experiment with every stone it
does perhaps mean that the experiment
must have been made with at least a
great number and from this we can then
by analogy draw an inference about the
rest with the greatest probability or
with perfect right but analogy not only
does not give a perfect right but on
account of its nature contradicts itself
so often that the inference to be short
drawn from analogy itself is rather than
analogy does not permit an inference to
be made probability which is what the
result would amount to loses in the face
in face of truth every distinction of
lesser and greater probability let it be
as great as it may it is nothing as
against truth but the instinctive reason
does in fact take such laws for truth
and it is when it does not discern
necessity in them that it comes to make
this distinction and reduces the truth
of the matter it's off to the level of
probability in order to indicate the
imperfect way in which truth presents
itself to the consciousness which is not
yet attained to insight into the pure
notion for universality is present only
as a simple immediate universality but
at the same time on account of this
universality the law has truth for
consciousness that a stone Falls is true
for
consciousness because in its happiness
the stone has in and for itself that
essential relation to the earth which is
expressed in falling consciousness thus
has an experience the being of the law
but it has to the law in the form of a
notion and it is only because of the two
aspects together that the law is true
for consciousness the law is valid as a
law because it is manifested in the
world of appearance and is also in its
own self a notion
here in paragraph 250 Hegel seems to be
talking quite a lot about the structure
of analogy and there are some quite
interesting remarks that he's making
there but they're in a larger context
that has to do with what we can infer
and what we can conclude about the
nature of law these reintroduce law in
the previous few paragraphs and he noted
the two sides that are involved in it
one is the notion and universality which
provides a kind of necessity without
which there is no law on the other hand
the law has to actually apply to things
empirical things things that we can
encounter can experience which are
sensible particulars which are
contingent so how does all of this play
itself out in the beginning of this
paragraph he talks about what I'm just
signaling here with an X as an
antithesis the way Miller translates it
or an opposition a contradiction of
Gagan Zots between the truth of law as
reality and there Hegel actually uses
the term reality tent that's just being
translated by its cognate reality and
the notion and the in itself or Miller
has intrinsic Universal why is there a
contradiction or an opposition or an
antithesis between these two between
these these you know ways of looking at
law he says well it's because
consciousness is remaining at the level
of observation notice that he doesn't
say that there is an intrinsic
contradiction that will never be
overcome he's saying that this is a
contradiction which is rising to the
fore and his point in observing reasons
activities as we are observing that
as phenomenologist so it says it does
not regard an object such as its lower
that's having the nature of reason but
fancies that it is something alien
something foreign to so what has to
happen here is for reason consciousness
in this this new Gestalt of the reason
to you might say read appropriate law
where itself that means understanding
its own connection with one so one of
the questions that we can ask here
that's not being framed as such in the
text but we're going to talk about the
passage that it's coming out of us what
does universality mean as applied to
sensuous beings and notice that I've got
this term all there because that's what
the universality is about allgemeinen
right everything so he says it
contradicts this is reason it's own
belief in the fact that does not take
its universality to mean that every
single sensuous thing must have provided
evidence of the law so if the law is
going to have universality presumably it
has to have universality in in two
distinguishable but but connected ways
one is presumably you know this is the
sort of science as predicting right
presumably it should tell us about
what's going to be observed if we have a
law that makes sense of a particular
range of phenomena and it really does
have a necessity then it should tell us
what we're going to see happen if this
is the case if we do this in the
experiment this way these are the
results that we should have that's one
side the other side is well where did
you get that information from in the
first place did you look at everything
and here is where hinkel's not actually
talking about this at this point
the little big Russian they think is
very useful for us when we are making
predictions and they're not merely
matters of probability statements but
matters about what has to be the case we
are engaging in deductive reasoning we
and that's the way a lot of science
works at least a tenth part of it right
it says granted that these conditions
are the case here's what we should
observe and of course it can be done in
terms of probability and statistics
let's put that aside for a moment though
in general what we're saying is we've
got deductive reasoning that can be done
providing an inference that should get
us from this stuff to here in every case
what's the basis coming from where did
you get that did you get that deductive
lis well as it turns out maybe some of
the stuff that got you there you got
deductive we put a lot of it you had to
acquire inductively that is by observing
things and generalizing now this area
universalizing but generalizing what
Hegel's you're going to call analogy or
analogizing from those particular cases
and it could be that your sample size
wasn't big enough
or it could be that you overlooked some
you know important factor there could be
all sorts of things that don't
necessarily validate but certainly
weaken inductive reasoning and as it
also turns out here we're getting a
little bit more into stuff that's being
away from from Hale per se although you
would find some of this discussed not
with these terms but but with these
concepts in his logic there's also a
curse calls abductive reasoning where
there's kind of a leap that's going on
that would make sense out of things
right now I'm not gonna try to explain a
deductive reasoning in detail here but
that also provides the basis for quite a
lot of our talk about laws and
regularities and the way things have to
go so all that said
what's the basis what does universality
mean as applied to all sensuous beats
hands going to his example of a stove he
says the assertion that stones fall when
raised above the ground and drop
certainly does not require us to make
this experiment with every stone why not
that's that's the the you might say the
back end right well I mean why not
because if you try to do that with every
single stone you'd never get done you
shouldn't ever conclude anything and
that would kind of contradict that the
the whole point to trying to have some
laws in the first place you know if you
if you have to know the entire universe
before you can say anything meaningful
well science never get started in the
first place as a matter of fact even
getting yourself out of bed never
happens in the first place so what else
does he say it does perhaps mean the
experiment must have been made at least
a great number inductive we don't want
just you know leaps in you know in the
dark and inferences from very very you
know a few phenomena instead we want to
you know done quite a few experiments
this is where we get to analogy so he
says we can by an analogy draw an
inference about the rest with the
greatest probability or with perfect
right now what is analogy the way that
any note is talking about it here
analogy can be used in more than one
sense of the term so those who've read
their Thomas Aquinas or who've read
glosses on Aristotle or who are reading
you know recurrent discussions about
metaphor don't get it all worked up
about this because Hegel means something
a bit different he's talking about
carrying out a process of imprints where
we are saying well things are in this
way in these cases so we're going to
generalize to all cases and so we
observe some stones and we see that when
we drop them they fall right unless
there's something
meaning and we haven't seen all stones
in the universe but we do say that we
know something about all stones and
Hegel says at this point it seems like
it's with perfect right or with the
greatest probability so that's an
analogy now how reliable is analogy
here's where he says that you've got a
problem since analogy not only does not
give a perfect right analogy is not a
deductive process here what we're
talking about as an inductive process on
account of its nature it contradicts
itself so often that the inference to be
drawn from analogy itself is rather than
analogy does not permit an inference to
be made what are we doing here we're
looking at analogy and such and some
analogies things work out like the
stones other analogies perhaps with the
body politic or with history or with
what my uncle is going to say when I
present him with this conundrum
maybe those analogies don't actually
work out yeah so when we look in an
objective way and analogies on a meta
level when we're looking as
consciousness looking in on analogies
what we should say is well we've got
this limited set of analogies we haven't
even looked at all of allergies yet but
from that we can actually conclude - all
analogies and what we can conclude is
that we can't really use analogies to
make reliable inferences reliable on
what sense here's where we get to the
the other part that that's quite
important that Hegel is going to move to
from this so he says probability which
is what we would give losses in the face
of truth every distinction of lesser and
greater probability so probability if
you take truth out of the picture truth
in you know sort of the robust sense
probability looks pretty good put it up
against what Hegel is calling truth here
which is you know to have some sort of
systematic reliable you know full
universal conception of the way things
actually are and probability starts to
look bad in comparison and what I've got
here is probability versus truth and
probability as truth now the question is
which are which are you going to take if
you accept analogy at this point then
your your same probability could
substitute for truth the probability can
give us the best thing that we can come
to for truth is a matter of fact that's
as good as it's going to get as
probability if there's something else
that we can compare it against and we
don't necessarily have to have that
completely sketched out at this point
then we have the versus relationship
probability versus trip management Hagel
is saying that we cannot working we may
not have fully worked out the notion of
it yet but we do have an operative you
might say so he goes out and he senses
the instinctive reason does in fact hits
take such laws for truth what is he
saying this is he's saying that the
instinctive reason takes analogy and the
laws that come from analogy and the
probability as truth that would be one
reading of this and then it's not a
stupid instinctive reason higgles not
saying that what Hegel is actually
saying is that in it's instinctive
activity reason is already employed in a
trying to not use the word notion of
consumption here he's using a grasp of
the grinch grasp right notice what we're
doing it's very hard to get away from
this even the language here so I'm not
even gonna bother reason has a notion
not completely worked out but a notion
of truth a notion of the notion as
something more than mere probability
and something more than mere being I say
how can you have anything more than
being being is all that there is
well-being unfolds itself within the
Hegelian dialectics so that it shows
that there's more you know as we go on
that there was originally evident at the
start it was all there at the start
actually but but it just wasn't
developed out so wha for Hegel in this
this section he says you need again
these two sides being or reality test
right what is effective what is actual
what is empirical what is confronting us
what we can experience and what goes
beyond that the notion which reason
congratz reason takes us beyond the
merely sensible reason takes us into
what is still sensible within the
sensible that we didn't grasp as as such
so he comes and he says reason does take
these laws of truth and it is when it
does not destroy necessity then it comes
to make this distinction and reduces the
truth of the matter to the level of
probability or to indicate the imperfect
way in which truth presents itself to
the consciousness which is not yet
attained insight into the pure notion
for universality is present only is a
simple immediate universality
that's an imperfect way of doing things
he says at the same time on account of
this the law has truth for consciousness
why does it blow I have truth for
consciousness not just because of this
side but because these two sides are
connected with each other in the law law
is more than just say a statement why is
something that reason brings to the
table and finds out there in nature so
he was out of my sense that a stone
falls is true for consciousness why just
because it
a whole bunch of times no because it
finds something else going on he says
because it's happiness the stone he has
in and for itself that essential
relation of the truth to the earth which
is expressed in following there is some
truth that is more than just the mere
phenomena that is being grasped and
relation even for itself between the
stone and the earth of this case we're
talking about gravity remember we saw
that this law of gravity applied not
only to stones but to all sorts of other
things and that's going to raise some
other you know issues which we saw
already come up in force in the
understanding but at Google some anime
says consciousness does it he hasn't
experienced the being of the law right
that's important but in hands to law in
front of notion only because of the two
aspects together the law is true for
consciousness you need this sign you
need the applicability of the law you
need this side the intelligibility of
the law the law is valid as implying
census because it is manifested in the
world of appearance and also because in
its own self it is a notion very
important realization about the nature
of law
because the law is at the same time in
itself a notion the instinct of reason
in this consciousness proceeds to refine
the law and its moments into an ocean it
does this of necessity but without
knowing that this is what it aims to do
it puts the law to the test of
experiment the law as it first appears
exhibits itself in an impure form
enveloped in single sensuous forms of
being and the notion constituting its
nature is immersed in an empirical
material in its experiments the instinct
of reason sets out to find what happens
in such and such circumstances the
result is that the law seems only to be
all the more immersed in sensuous being
the inner significance of this
investigation is to find the pure
conditions of the law and this means
nothing else even if the consciousness
expressing its meaning in this way were
to think it meant something different
than to raise the law into the form of
notion and to free its moments
completely from being tied to a specific
being for example negative electricity
which first which at first comes to be
known say as resin electricity and
positive electricity as glass
electricity these as a result of
experiments lose all together such as
significance and become purely positive
and negative electricity neither of
which is any longer attached to a
particular kind of thing and we can no
longer say that there are bodies which
are positively electric electrical and
others which are negatively electrical
in the same way the relationship of acid
and base and their reaction constitute a
law in which these opposite sides
appears bodies but these separated
detach things have no actuality the
power which forces them apart cannot
prevent them from at once entering again
into a process where they are only this
relation they can not like a tooth or a
claw remain a part on their own and as
such be pointed out this essential
nature of their is to pass over
immediately into a neutral product makes
their being into a being which is
implicitly superseded or universal an
acid and base
have truth only as universals therefore
just as glass and resin can just as well
be positively as negatively electrical
in the same way acid and base are not
tied as properties to this or that
actuality each thing is only relatively
acid or base what seems to be an
absolute base or acid gets in the so
called
sin so Mahdi's the opposite significance
in relation to something else the result
of the experiments is in this way to
cancel the moments or activated signs as
properties of specific things and to
free the predicates from their subjects
these predicates are found only as
universals as in truth they are because
of this self subsistence they get the
name of matters which are neither prop
bodies nor properties and certainly no
one would call oxygen positive and
negative electricity heat and so forth
bodies
in paragraph 251 Hegel is continuing
what he began doing in paragraph 250 but
now we're going to see an important
shift take place one you might say in in
arrangement and and then the
corresponding understanding so in the
last paragraph we have law as involving
these two different moments actually
more than one paragraph before that one
was the you might say the empirical side
that particulars the contingent right of
the being of the law and then on the
other side we have the notion and the
law should also be notion should be a
necessity should be universality and
these two exists in became a dynamic
tension now what's going to happen is
there's going to be a shift right and
we're going to move from one to the
other and that's what's happening here
Hegel is sketching out for us a dynamic
process by which we move from the
empirical to the concept the notion that
the drift right and it's talking about
reason doing this without necessarily
planning it out because what we're
talking about here is reason the way
that the Miller is translating it is
that you know reason is doing the
instinctive reasons is how it caused it
in this passage it does this without
necessarily you know reasoning this out
is the best way to do it it's fear
nourished instinct in German just reason
as at stake the instinctive reason
however you want to translate it the
point is what we've got going here is
this is what reason does when you let it
do what it does when you don't interfere
with it in some way like say making it
work all day long right previous
passages previous dialectics when it's
not caught up with all sorts of other
stuff this is what reason can actually
do by virtue of you know being raised so
he says the instant of reason in this
kind
as proceeds to refine the law there's
this process refining that's going to be
taking place and we're sort of moving it
from one thing to another thing and he
sketches this out in a couple different
ways first he talks about refining the
law and its moments it's things that
it's applying to right into the notion
and what is the notion of the notion of
law so we have water being no longer
just present on this side present on
this side these exist and require each
other we're moving from this which is
okay but not what we really want to this
which is what we really want he fills
the cinnamon he tells us more about
these things in these passages he talks
about the law in its moments as being
enveloped in sensuous forms of being
that is it is it is caught up in
sensibility it is caught up in like he
says the notion is immersed in empirical
material so we know what are examples of
that he's got to know physical examples
which are quite interesting but we could
talk about say observing a human
behavior and you know we get to know you
know the way that human beings react
let's think about for example the nature
of anger and you know are there any laws
that we might deduce about anger or
watch a lot of angry people and we see
that they respond in certain ways and if
we stay just bound up with the
particulars bound up with the cases
bound up with the studies bound up with
the you know what and what is in front
of our eyes maybe what gets us involved
feeling as well we're never going to get
to the generality let alone the
universality that we want in law here
what we're aiming for are the pure
conditions of the law right we're trying
to say well what is the structure what
is the intelligible thing that runs
through all of these we're this he also
talks about it's being freed from the
specific being but let's make that
plural it's free from that home
careful with a mess of empirical
material that is what the notion is
supposed to give us we've got some
examples here that we'll go into in just
a moment
we do things about the examples Daniel
chooses so he says the laws it first
appears exhibits itself in an impure
form this is impure
we want to get the purified form right
in its experiments you says the
instinctive reason sets us to find out
what happens in such and such
circumstances
now the experiments can just sort of
circle around and keep coming right back
to this spot and you know you fill up
your laboratory notebook full of all
sorts of observations but you're never
actually draw any general conclusions
well you're doing a very good chemistry
experiment then because you're not
supposed to just say oh pretty lungs
when you you know put this salt in with
powdered powder and iron and throw it in
the Bunsen burner right or when you put
these two you know compounds together
they precipitate this other thing out
which is really cool you're not supposed
to observe that you're supposed to be
drawing general conclusions about what's
supposed to happen across the board when
you do that kind of experiment with that
kind stuff but also about other things
like about the nature of precipitation
out of you know you know a solution in
general right or capillary action or
think about things that when you were a
kid they made you putter around with it
maybe you found fascinating or maybe fun
deadly boring probably had a lot to do
through your teacher was so he says it
sets out to find out what happens with
such and such circumstances so the one
that appears to be more immersed in such
as being the inner significance of the
investigation is to get to here this is
what this is where the action is you
might say this is what the experiments
are supposed to be about they're not
then we don't have progress being made
so he goes on he says we want to raise
the law to the form of notion free it's
moments from being conscious
now he starts giving examples now before
we start looking at these examples I do
want to say once again as I've said it a
few previous passages then when it comes
to natural science we know a lot more
than Hagel did at his own time he is
relying on sort of a representative
sample of some of the you know the
battery physical and chemical and
biological studies available to him at
the time there's theories that that he
endorses that we you know with what we
know about physical things like for
example acids and bases can't really get
behind and what we have to do at this
point is choose between a couple of
alternatives one is we can say we're
just going to blank out this portion of
the text or like redactors so wherever
he go made some sort of mistake and it
doesn't conform to our current pretty
good understanding of physical science
and we just throw that crap we're not
even going to bother looking at it it's
a bit of baby with the bathwater they're
you know throwing out way too much to do
that the other extreme would be to say
hey you must be right in some sort of
way so we're going to find some way to
make this work that's not going to be a
viable solution either and you're not
going to see me trying to do that
because I've seen enough other people
try to do that and the results of that
are used you know at best chemical yeah
at worst tragic and you know what
remains to us in between well let's try
to figure out what the hell he was
trying to get at in telling us and see
whether there really is something
valuable that's being conveyed in in his
discussion of this maybe he's wrong
about the nature of acids and bases to
some degree but maybe there's some way
in which this actually does make sense
and let's keep that and let's not trying
to say well now the whole edifice falls
apart because it doesn't we can go on to
three
sections even within or further
paragraphs even within this section and
say well that that perfec there didn't
quite make sense or it doesn't conform
to what we know just as much as you know
Eagles criticisms of stoicism for
example are not entirely non-base but
when you see what he's driving at then
it does fall into place within the
dialectic and it's okay for Hegel to be
wrong about some things you know we
could still do commentary
I'm Hale it's still a valuable activity
it's still valuable for you to be
studying the text what you want to think
about is the balance of riots over
overdraw all right so let's look at the
specific examples that he uses here he
uses physical examples that were
fascinating everybody at the time
electricity he talks in terms of
positive and negative electricity acids
and bases you know chemistry was not in
its infancy but was its early stages
let's say it was nowhere near what it
what it was later 19th century level in
20th century now what is he drawing from
this okay so think about what we've got
here those things like positive and
negative electricity acid and base as
such those are what we're talking about
over here as the notion of the law we're
talking about physical phenomena but
we're talking about them in a very
general way that we take for granted
because you know this is a hard one
achievement that reason in history and
to work out and we just you know open up
our high school chemistry text or you
know whatever and you know on page 10
tells us well acids have a pump they
have a you know pH between this range of
that ranging off up to seven right bases
from seven on up well there's the
neutral zone of course electricity works
in these ways we even have you know
great explanations about the latest
science you know where a positive and
negative electrical charge come from how
they
you know how static happens they didn't
handle that at that time and and those
things again were won by reason carrying
out this process of refining so what
does he start out talking about well the
sort of things that when we have
children learn by doing with electricity
we have them play around with so he
talks for example about reson
electricity and glass electricity now we
need we can do other things we're happy
to do things playing around with static
charges and balloons and the kid might
associate electricity well you get this
from this thing and you get this from
from this thing and Hegel's saying no if
we want to talk about the generality we
get away from those particular materials
same thing with acident and base he says
you know he says well look before we get
to that state it says negative
electricity comes to be known as reson
electricity positive electricity as
glass electricity these as a result of
experiments lose such significance and
become purely positive and negative
electricity neither of which is any
longer attached to a particular kind of
thing and we can no longer say that
there are bodies which are positively
electrical and others are negatively
electrical we realized that we we can
produce a charge in something we can you
know produce another the opposite charge
in things as well but it's not
necessarily tied to the the bodies of
the trooper in this case he goes ahead
and he says these things are not like a
tooth or a claw that remain apart on
their own can be pointed out this
essential nature of there is to pass
over immediately into a neutral product
mix of being a being which is implicitly
superseded or a universal right you see
the heel really laces right they they
can be superseded they can be alcohol
but and they they are universal now he
talks about the acid and base the acid
base have truth only as universals says
just as glass and resin can just as well
be positively as
Electrical in the same way acid and base
are not tied his properties to this or
that actuality each thing is will be
relatively acid their base what seems to
be an absolute base or acid gets in many
so here he talked about the since
emani's I have to admit I don't really
understand the significance of that I've
looked through the commentaries
different people have different things
to say about it it appears to be sort of
a blind alley that you don't really
think know much about in the park
because what we do know is that acid and
base turn out to be properties of things
they are relative right but they
actually do belong to certain things and
Institute with hydrogen and oxygen and
then you try to put oxygen at the end by
the way base or acid I'm sorry in German
is a sour right literally sour but with
a capital S or not showing that it's a
substantive and oxygen is the sour stuff
so that's what he talks about oxygen
yeah yeah now we know that that physical
science has taught us things that he is
is in contradiction with on this so for
example you can't just make anything
that's the thing no you could make your
your body more acidic or more base but
your body is a massive composition of
all sorts of things you can't actually
make I mean you can make your stomach
acid less acid by diluting it but you're
not going to turn it into a base because
then it's not going to stomach acid
right so he is roaring about that what
is he getting at here that is valuable
he said that these are not really bodies
as such and that group they don't exist
attached from each other so they're not
non-relative acid is relational to base
base is relational to ask the positive
and negative electricity or relational
to each other that is actually correct
now you know we we could imagine
universe I suppose in which there was no
base because nothing had a pH level
above 7 that's a very difficult universe
to imagine but I suppose it could be
done but it's so far away from from
where we are that I don't know that that
really helps us out much he also said
something else he says that these are
the result of the experiment is to
cancel the moments are activated
Sciences properties of specific things
and to free them free the predicates
from their subjects acid becomes a
predicate base becomes a predicate a
general predicate a predicate which is a
universal and which he's going to use a
term here that Miller is translating as
he has to as materials maturity which is
different than matter or in the sense of
we're used to thinking of it or as
bottoms right bodies in this translating
cooker so these predicates that you
acids and bases you're a positive
negative electricity or you might say
physical phenomena that have some sort
of basis in themselves but are relative
to others and that is how they are
universal so that's what he's trying to
assert here says they're neither bodies
nor properties and so you know what are
examples of this oxygen positive
negative electricity heat and and so
forth these are going to poverty's these
are what he's calling my Terry you know
materials these predicates these
universals this is going to have an
importance a little bit later in the
next section so they don't want to say
too much about it here but Hegel is
trying to show us by using these
examples how reason in its instinctual
activity carries out this refining
process so we get positive and negative
electricity rather than just you know
can't electricity and slipper and carpet
electricity we we get the the
general conception of it